[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
June 13th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
people place bets on online Sports
gambling sites every year and the IRS
wants to know about those bets Wall
Street Journal tax reporter Laura
Saunders joins us with what sports
gamblers should know about paying taxes
on their winnings so Laura first of all
how does the IRS find out about
someone's wins and losses from sports
betting sites well when you're gambling
online you're making those fourth bets
there's a record of every one of them at
the companies this is the great thing
about online and digital activities the
companies are keeping records when you
go onto your phone and you make a parlay
or a prop bed or something like that
that's all in the company's computer's
memory and then that gets reported to
the IRS well it doesn't always get
reported to the IRS they're different
thresholds for different kinds of
gambling activity now with a lot of
those Sports bets the threshold is
really high the win will be reported if
the odds were 300 to 1 or greater and
the winning is more than six hundred
dollars so that's a pretty high
threshold so how are the winnings taxed
and how would somebody report them on
their tax return let's talk about how it
works for casual gamblers it means
people who are not professional gamblers
if you're a normal ordinary Gambler your
winnings are taxed as ordinary income at
ordinary income rights like wages
however when it goes on your tax return
it goes on line 8B of schedule 1 as
gambling income gambling winnings but
not everybody who wins on every bet how
do their losses fit into this equation
well this is really important because
gambling winnings are ordinary income on
one part of the return but gambling
losses can only be deducted as an
itemized deduction on schedule a this is
where you deduct mortgage interest and
medical expenses and state and local
taxes there's also a place to put in
gambling losses let's say you have seven
thousand dollars of winnings and 7 the
two hundred dollars of losses then seven
thousand dollars of your losses would be
deductible against your winnings
assuming that you itemize and can do
this but there's a real catch here Jr
and it is that since the tax overhaul of
2017 very few people have itemized their
deductions the people who itemized have
gone from about a third of taxpayers to
probably less than 10 percent so what
that means is that if you're gambling
online doing sports betting you could be
in a position where all of your winnings
are taxable but your losses are not
deductible and does that have to do with
a standard deduction being raised yes it
does in 2017 the tax overhaul about
doubled the standard deduction so that
for this year it's over thirteen
thousand dollars now you take a young
Gambler a male in his 20s or something
like that he probably doesn't have a
mortgage he doesn't have anything much
but his gambling losses and so he he'll
take this standard deduction but he
won't get a specific break for his
losses in that case while his winnings
are still taxable you know we talk about
tax returns in the IRS and things get
really complicated why wouldn't somebody
just subtract their losses from their
winnings and then just report that
number well they'd like to be able to
but that's not what the law says we
think
the IRS says that's not what the loss
are some professionals that think you
could do that if you have sessions this
is like say if you walked into Las Vegas
and you played slots for five hours and
you could look at the amount at the
beginning and the man at the end and
take the losses away from the winnings
there are some professionals that think
you should be able to do that with
online Sports bets and that a judge
would agree with you but the IRS doesn't
agree with you and you might get into a
fight with him before you get to court
all right well that leads me to the next
question is this the sort of thing that
could raise a red flag at the IRS and
result in an audit well yes first they
have to hear about it you know if you
had a great big hit
something like that the other thing is
that Revenue agents know that people
gamble so that if they're doing a
regular audit and they see something
like a deduction for a business trip to
Las Vegas they will raise the gambling
question so they're very alert to that
let's talk for a moment about people who
bet at casinos a lot of times people's
winnings include just exchanging chips
for cash then they walk away from the
cash window and they're done is the IRS
interested in those winnings also yes it
is and it's the same rules basically as
for online sports betting and what
happens is that you're supposed to put
your winnings on one part of the return
your losses on another unless you're a
professional which most people aren't
but again those things aren't
necessarily reported to the IRS unless
they're over a certain amount for slot
machines it's 1200 and blackjack and
poker and Krebs they all have different
thresholds those are easily available on
the IRS website but we've had this
explosion of betting since it was
legalized around the country and it's
not just people in their 20s who are
doing this it's college students do they
know what they're up against I think
they don't and I bet their parents don't
know either now maybe this is a little
bit like household help most people
don't pay attention to the law but
there's a slice of people that need to
be very concerned if their children are
doing sports betting and the child is a
dependent like a college student then
the child probably needs to file or
return the gambling winnings or taxable
as ordinary income the losses are
probably not deductible there's no
standard deduction it gets really
complicated really fast and there's some
questions we don't even know the answer
to like whether those winnings are
subject to the kitty tax that's when an
income is taxed at the parents right but
it is an important thing for parents to
be aware of if their children are doing
online sports betting so with all the
betting going on below the threshold you
talked about that the IRS wants to know
about there's a lot of honor System
stuff going on here isn't there yes
there absolutely is and so how does that
work well I think the best advice that I
heard from the professionals is to keep
a very very good record of your wins and
losses the Irish knows that most people
who are betting or gambling are losing
more than they win and so if you can
show the IRS that you lost more than you
won you may not have a problem with all
this in an audit but you need to have
the records and many people don't do
that now you've spoken to CPAs and tax
advisors about this what do they tell
their clients they do a lot of betting I
did talk to a CPA at a firm that handles
a lot of returns for online Sports
Bettors and other gamblers and are very
familiar with this and when he talks to
his clients and he explains the rules he
says they're really surprised they say
is this worth it because it seems like
everybody wins the companies the IRS the
states everybody wins except the Gambler
himself well that's been the formula for
a hundred years hasn't it yeah and
longer maybe maybe much longer that's
Wall Street Journal tax reporter Laura
Saunders and that's your money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]